so hello everybody I'm here with Paul
Vander clay for those who haven't seen
some of his videos on YouTube he's been
pretty active in the last what two
months now or maybe a month and a half
right two months he's been pretty active
in following what Jordan Peterson has
been doing and giving an interpretation
of what he's doing kind of trying to
connect it and show how what he's saying
is is is similar and different from his
own Christian tradition and so I thought
it would be a really interesting
discussion to to have with them to talk
maybe about Jordans place in the big
discussion right now about religion and
then after that talk a little bit more
about Bible interpretation and about
symbolism
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world so Paul maybe you can
give a quick introduction to who you are
and where you are and what you're what
you're doing in life well Jonathan just
it's it's a pleasure to meet you I've
been following your videos and really
enjoying them and I this is all new to
me I'm a pastor in Sacramento California
I've been a pastor here at this
particular Congregation for 20 years
I've been in the ministry for now about
27 years but I'm also a third generation
minister so so the church has always in
a sense been our family business and I
got interested in Jordan Peterson a lot
of the in in many of the same ways that
everyone else seems to have I actually
it was rod rod drear's blog that I was
reading quite regularly and he had made
a comment about Peterson at one point
and so I kind of followed it up and and
said oh here's a here's an academic in
Toronto who's kind of stepping out of
the herd isn't that interesting and then
I kind of I didn't think about it much
for a while and then I caught one of the
videos of the protesters and what really
struck me was how how calm he was in the
midst of the melee and that impressed me
and that I thought I want to hear more
of what he has to say and then I saw
that he was doing these biblical series
and he's selling out these this concert
hall in in Toronto and I know I knows I
have some friends who passed her in
Toronto and I thought well their
churches are empty and this dude on a
Tuesday night and people are paying to
see and people are traveling there to
see ya I got a listen to this so then I
start listening to it and I'm I'm a
little bit addictive and once I find
something that's interesting I can't let
it go and so then of course I listen to
all the biblical series and I listen to
maps of meaning and I listen to the
personalities course and and and then I
started and I've been blogging I've been
blogging for a long long time and just a
tiny little obscure blog I'm known in my
denomination but beyond it not too much
and so I had written some blog posts
about him and that was just kind of fun
but then I was reading I always point
this up in my in my videos um Neil
postman's amusing ourselves to death I
was rereading that at the same point and
I thought you know he there's something
integral about peterson and youtube this
medium and so if i'm gonna engage his
work I really should maybe try and make
a video and I've been playing around
with video a little bit so I made a
video and I made another video and the
second video just kind of took off and I
had had like 15 subscribers for for six
years on my channel and I wake up one
day and I've got 300 I thought well
that's weird and the next day I had you
know 400 and 500 and by the time it hit
2000 I was thoroughly unnerved because I
thought I don't want this messing up my
life and then after a while it kind of
settled down and so and I kind of
figured it out and then it was cool so
and this is what I've been doing but but
I do this because I am kind of I am kind
of a pitbull when I get an idea that
interests me and I don't let the darn
thing go and I've just got to process it
to death and enough people are like oh
do more so alright i'll process it with
the camera on so maybe you can tell us I
mean I have my own take on this then
maybe I'll go into a bit later and I've
talked about it a little bit in
different talks but maybe you can tell
us why you think it's important to to
deal with what Jordan is saying to the
world especially coming from your own
perspective as a as a pastor why you
think that what he's saying is important
and why it's it's worth as a pastor
getting involved in it and getting
involved into the in the discussion
well well one one issue was clearly I
began so I'm put up my videos and the
next Sunday you know in in comes the guy
who's been watching my videos and says
I've been watching your videos and I've
never been to church before and so here
I am and he gives me he gives me the
poster of jordan peterson and it's law
as a pastor this is like well yeah this
is this is you know shoot churches do
all kinds of how many cockamamie things
to meet new people and here people are
just offering themselves and everything
the next week another guy comes in and
the next week another guy comes in and
so my church is kind of so I asked my
churches says what do you think of this
in there and they kind of look at me
like well I don't know I said well it's
easier than VBS so I'll keep doing it
Vacation Bible School that's you know
yeah churchy stuff so but but when I
listen to Peterson part part of the
issue that I've done I've thought about
for a long time is that there's a real
disconnect in the modern period between
a lot of the stuff that you talk about
in terms of the symbolic world of the
Bible and the assumed world of regular
people and so actually I've done a fair
amount of teaching on this and in some
colleges and friends of mine who are
university professors will have me come
in and talk about this where everyone
I'll ask people you know is the world
around or flat well it's round well how
do you know that it's round well I saw
that picture from the moon well now
actually the Greeks figured this out a
long time ago but so so in other words
in the imaginary space of the world you
know we're on a globe spinning through
space but in the biblical story that the
world looks very different and so what's
the relationship a little story our
actual existing life we don't live we
don't live on a round world that's
floating in space or you know around the
Sun we live on a world that has the
ground down here and the sky up there
and that's our lived reality so that's
where the Bible that's how the Bible
talks about the world because that's how
we live exactly and and I think the
disconnect in people as a pastor that
diskant that that separates them from
the Bible and it separates them from God
and so when you start getting into
pastoral issues that the Bible the Bible
isn't terribly useful for them and a lot
of what's happened in biblical theology
and in biblical studies over the last
200 years hasn't been useful at all yeah
it's it's been partly useful and so and
so when I saw
her said I said huh this could be
helpful and so then I started and and
the first thing I started when I started
listening to Peterson was CS Lewis
mm-hmm yeah and I and I thought I want
to I want to have CS Lewis in on this
conversation with Jordan Peterson now CS
Lewis died of the air I was born so what
does that mean so so but he wrote a lot
so that's that's where I'm where I'm
going with my videos but before I've
just started that process actually but I
needed to talk a lot before I could get
there yeah well you know it's funny
because when I kind of discovered
orthodoxy in the West and I converted
and everything one of the things I
discovered is that a lot of Orthodox
priests and and people love CS lewis and
love token they almost feel as if
they're that kind of the medieval the
the rediscovery of a medieval worldview
that Lewis was was trying to get people
to see is what needs to happen today and
that's what that's that's exactly what I
think too is that we need to be able to
rediscover that the lived experience and
and and help people to see that that has
value and once you see that then a lot
of the stories of the Bible a lot of the
problems and the stories of the Bible
disappear I mean I just recently I told
a priest that I said you have you have
problems with dragons okay fine but just
interpret the word dragon in terms of
phenomenology the problem goes away it
just vanishes because it just means a
monster that's kind of that's on the you
know on the edge of being and so then
you don't it's it's gone so the story of
st. George is not a problem at all who
cares what it act like let's say st.
George killed some beast like it it
doesn't matter what it was in terms of
its biological you know name even if you
could give it its biological name you're
missing the point of the story which is
that it's a it's a crazy thing that has
that's coming out from the pit and has
it has a mixture I said you know maybe
it was a like like a two-headed you know
a crocodile with with elephantitis or
something like who cares what it was
doesn't matter he was a monster you know
like there's no bile
category four for a two-headed crocodile
with elephantitis you know it just
and who has rabies at the same time or
something who knows yeah so that's oh so
engaging with that has definitely been
something that I've seen that has
brought me close to it to Jordan is I
never had never thought about it in
terms of science ever I was actually
quite hostile to that hostile but let's
say oppositional to science I wrote an
article a few years ago called most of
the time the earth is flat yeah and so
it was it was trying to say like how
much the scientific worldview had
invaded our perceptions and how it was
actually damaging to our understanding
of traditional story but also our
understanding of our daily life how that
how we don't live in that in the let's
say in the cosmos described by black
holes and in all these these we don't
live in that world it's a it's an
abstract world but then when I heard
Jordan I and he talked about neuro like
neurology and and in the brain and and
this idea that we're kind of built in a
way that these patterns are are
physically built into our brain and I
mean I had heard of young before and
I've never been really interested in him
and still I'm not that interested in him
and but but the idea that were
constructed that way no matter how it is
that we got there like if evolution made
us that way doesn't matter that's how
we're made and that the stories that the
Bible bring out and that traditional
stories bring out are actually tapping
in or a kind of program that that runs
and and they fine-tune our perceptions
to to be aligned with that that that
biological program I was like it really
it that's that's what made me kind of
reach out to to to Jordan when I heard
him I heard him talk on the radio like a
few years ago and I was like oh there's
something interesting here that's worth
exploring that it can be helpful for
what I'm trying to do and so yeah that's
how it all started for me and and part
of what I really appreciated about him
very early on was he's a clinical
psychologist with a clinical practice
and so I my father was a pastor in a in
Paterson New Jersey and very distressed
very poor
you know in the 60s full of heroin crime
and that's that's where I grew up and
and so I had always known chaos and and
I had always been immersed in you know
clinical psychologist sit in a room and
people maybe I'm being a little biased
people come in and meet them but as a
pastor you're kind of immersed in it you
don't have the clear boundaries and so
you know when he's telling his stories
about you know the guy who you know a
guy who loves his dog and I mean this is
this has been my life my whole life and
including the church I passed her and
now I and and so when I when I hear I
heard these stories and then I saw his
kind of his chaos order construct I said
oh boy that really works yeah and I can
use that pastors are thieves we're not
only Liars were also thieves and when we
find something that's useful we grab it
and we run with it well one of the
things one of the things that is one of
the things that really attracted me I
mean the word order and chaos is is is
the word that you use it you could use
like in the in the church fathers you
get the sense the notion of death like
just the notion of death itself this
really is this idea of fragmentation and
kind of falling apart at the edge and
and the idea of Hades and all that so
and so it was easy for me to map to map
like the order chaos paradigm that he
was using on to the issue the center
periphery and like the order death
images it's using in the Bible and in
the church fathers and then because I
was already talking about that stuff
before I was I was talking about logos
before too that's why he called me
because I told him I said you have to
listen to this talk I did where I'm
talking about the logos and how the
logos brings things together and and so
and and you know just kind of answering
these quick emails and then finally he
called me because he saw that yeah where
where does this come from like I never
heard like I never thought other people
were talking about this and I was like
it's there it's in the it's in the
father is like it's crazy this is it
this is Christianity you know this is
what Christianity is about so so so yeah
so that was interesting
so how has been I'm I'm gonna ask you a
big question what has been the reaction
of other pastors around you in terms of
this because that's something that I've
been having too
deal with myself yeah it's been mixed
there so and I'm a part of a
denomination it's about quarter of a
million people it's called the Christian
forum Church of North America it's it
was founded by Dutch immigrants and it's
the pretty it's got a very thick culture
and in some ways some people argue it's
it's it's a quasi extended family
sometimes literally because it's an
immigrant Church and it's not as much as
it was say 50 years ago
but so when I started talking about this
there's a Facebook group a closed
Facebook group just of CRC pastor I
started talking about this and a few
pastors were very excited because they
had also been secretly watching this
stuff and they're like oh you too ooh
and then other pastors usually I know
especially on actually Canadian pastors
have been on both sides
he Peterson had been getting a lot of
bad press in Canada right and this I'm
also quite interested in and what I see
as what is essentially a the the culture
war I think is essentially a Christian
is a Christian civil war mm-hmm because
it's two sides of Christianity you have
the kind of the cold war you have the
cold war civil religion and now we have
this ascendant morality kind of probably
neo-marxist civil religion that's
supplanting the Cold War religion and so
and these divisions are even within my
denomination which is a pretty
conservative denomination and so we're
right away when people here you know
someone talking about pronouns or and
I've never heard Jordan Peterson in
everything I've listened to him say a
word against you know gay people or
trans people I've never heard that but
his his his disagreement with refusing
to signal along these culture war tribal
lines you know even you know impacts
people's kind of low resolution take on
him so boom not he's you shouldn't be
listening to him
be talking about him and then the
association with young doesn't help
because most people don't know anything
about young but what they do know is you
know some vague connection with the
occult or with New Age movement so once
you lose name comes up a whole bunch of
people just check out hmm but some
pastors you know I've been around a long
time in the Christian form Church my
father and grandfather were pastors in
this denomination so in a sense I'm a
known quantity and I'm kind of known for
kind of being on the left side of the
denomination so and I passed her a
church that is at least half
african-american so I get a pass people
don't suspect me of being a racist so
they can't charge me with that and then
I talk about Peterson and and then I
just play the missional card on him I
say hey you know there are there are
thousands of people out there who are
interested in following the Bible it's
like where are you to talk to those
people yeah this is my job and so you
know so I and I'm also at a point in my
career you know I'm 54 I you know where
am I gonna go from here so I I say what
I want I've always said what I wanted so
but when I when I when I started doing
this some of my friends who know me just
said oh what you're doing what you
always do you're just doing it on
YouTube that's pretty much true yeah
I've had I've had to deal with it was
been very weird because at first my
relationship with Jordan was very it was
just I was friends with him and and then
it we did this video the crazy
metaphysics of a video on his channel
and that kind of that was very Snow's
weird weird weird and then yeah and then
recently I had a very very some strange
events where some clergy that I was
actually quite close to just told me
that they had to disassociate themselves
with me publicly they said because
you're an extreme right-wing guy that's
like what it's like you're almost a
fascist and I was like we're like we're
in the heavens could you get and it was
really I think it's really just that
somehow they somehow they heard
something about
being all trite or being whatever or
something and then they had their so
they decided that to put me kind of next
to him and so I mean we need to
disassociate with you because of that
and even the idea of disassociating
yourself with someone and not being
willing to engage in a discussion with
someone because they're someone mate
they somehow make you less pure or
something something like that that's
very that's very disturbing to me and
it's I haven't I had never had to deal
with that and and now I had to ask
myself questions about that about that
itself about you know oh so if I speak
to you now I'm like crypto Protestant
like is that what it is no and and and I
thought I don't know it doesn't seem
like that's what Christ was doing he was
you know he was talking and he was
calling out people when they needed to
be called out but he was also even the
Pharisees like he said to the Pharisees
you hypocrites but then he also said you
know the Pharisees are sitting in the
seat of Moses you know like what they're
saying is fine they're just hypocrites
and so it's so I just thought okay yeah
I'm just thought I'm just gonna keep
going I'm not going to people were
asking me like why don't you denounce
this why don't you denounce that that
Jordans saying why don't you dislike
yourself and I in but and then you and
then you fall like I tweeted I think you
saw that I tweeted something about how I
never said never cited Jung before and
after that I was like I should have done
that like this you know it's like it's
true that I'm not interested in young
but it's like I'm you know I'm giving
them I'm making making people happy that
oh now he's disassociating himself it's
weird that you have to ask yourself
these questions all of a sudden well and
I think I think we're all getting an
education in dealing dealing with this
kind of context and and one of the
things that you learn is self self
defense is really hard and often
counterproductive because people are
gonna think what they're gonna think and
the best thing you can do is is do what
you know you should do and again I
really appreciate Peterson's emphasis on
this so one of the things that happened
immediately after that so I have these
people starting to come to my church and
that is a pastor I always have an out
Stan
I said if you're a visitor to my church
I will I will take you out to lunch cuz
I want to hear your story and so then
I'd start talking to people who who've
been who've been interested in Peterson
and he's had a remarkable impact on a
lot of people's lives and and for the
better and and not just for the better
in terms of a Christian sense but they
you know they want to be better fathers
they want to love their wives better
they want to be more responsible they
want to keep their commitments they want
to tell the truth and it's like III
don't I don't care where you're from
this is you know this is basic and so
this is this is this is what you're
criticizing this guy for I mean oh okay
well well what's your agenda I actually
appreciated your tweet about young
because it you know when I when I try
and kind of locate all of this I mean
part of what's beautiful about the
eastern about the Orthodox Church and
now it's I read an article a few years
ago that talked about how I mean this
church was in some ways kind of weakened
and fragmented throughout you know the
part of the Christian world that really
took hits with with Islam and and and
but but when as I've seen this church
coming to America it's it's become less
ethnocentric and and I think in some
ways unleashed and so what this has
meant especially for people whose
traditions come from the West and the
Latin root now suddenly we're getting
reintroduced to the riches that the
Latin Church didn't have access to
mmm-hmm and and I think ironically you
know America in the United States is has
always been a place that intensified
both intensified religion but also
forced it to be trans cultural and so I
you know I'm fascinated by what's
happening with the with the Orthodox
Church here we hope so I think that I
think that is definitely when you're on
the
inside it feels like a war sometimes
because of course the ethnic question is
the big question you know in terms of
the structure of the Orthodox Church in
theory there should be one Orthodox
Church in one place right so let's say
there's a city there should be one
bishop and there should be priests and
you know like that's how it should go
but that's not how it is so you have so
every like every ethnic Church has kind
of preserved their own churches in in
the country and so I would say that that
in a way is the weakest testimony of
Orthodoxy in terms of its presence in
the u.s. but at the same time there's
been some considerable efforts from the
part of the Russian coming from the
Russian tradition coming from the
Antiochian tradition let's say to really
open up and to to talk about the Church
Fathers and to try to talk in a way that
that Westerners can understand and to to
to use a language that is maybe more
accessible to people and to also open up
their churches and make them accessible
for people because if you you know you
go to the if you go to a like a really
kind of strict Greek parish like you
want you'll go in there and it's like
you're in another planet you don't you
don't know what to do you don't were to
stand you don't know where to look like
you know people are doing things and
they're speaking in another language but
at least at the the OCA the Orthodox
Church of America which I'm part of and
the Antiochian parish is especially in
the United States they have they have
mostly in in English sometimes with a
little bit of Russian or a little bit of
Arabic to kind of you know to to to
connect to the to where they come from
but in general it's quite accessible
like my parish is French my my it's the
only maybe not the only by now but it's
like it's it's one of maybe two or three
French parishes in all of all of North
America really that's fascinating yeah
that's fascinating yeah so we get I mean
we get our translations from France and
stuff but it's kind of its kind of
interesting my parish is very small we
have maybe on a good Sunday there's like
20 people it's like this miniature
miniature Farish God God loves small
churches and if he didn't there wouldn't
be so many of them
and what so I was before before I was in
Sacramento I was in the Dominican
Republic and I worked with Haitians who
were illegal mostly cutting sugarcane
and picking coffee in in the
southwestern part of the country and
most of those churches to be a church he
needed ten baptized members at any given
time two or three of them were under
discipline and you know else but and and
so op dotted in the hills and in the
sugarcane communities I mean they're all
these tiny little churches of five ten
fifteen twenty people but you know God
and quirky and odd and wrong and you
know all over the place but I I'm I am
convinced that God just loves these
little huddled groups and my
congregation too you know
on a Sunday morning there's you know 50
or 60 or 75 Souls here and but I I
wouldn't have it any other way I love it
oh that's great that's great I lived you
know it's funny I lived in I don't you
know I lived in Africa for seven years
no yeah we're kind of doing this icon
carving I was in Congo for four years
and in Kenya for three years and in
Congo I really got like the extreme
version of that small church where we
lived with because the organization I
was with we really lived in local
neighborhoods so we didn't live in like
white enclave we lived like really in
with with with the local people and the
first house where we stayed the
neighbors to the left they had a church
and then the neighbors two streets to
two houses to the right had a church and
the neighbors on the diagonal from us
they had a church there was like there
was another church which was a little
further down the street like I didn't
know exactly where it was but it was
like a little further down the street
and they would and they and they they
would like they would pray like pray all
the time and like with like loudspeakers
they love the loudspeaker we got like
three churches at the same time at like
10 o'clock at night you know what on
Wednesday and and you're just sitting
there in your house and and it's like
you think wow like this is what it means
another culture like seriously like you
just you can't believe what's happening
and yeah so that was a really like yeah
it was it was a shocker to kind of
plunge into that world of like all these
these little churches everywhere
it was amazing though one time there was
a pastor like pastor next door on the
left he was going and going and going
and going for like three hours with his
with the microphone and I thought oh
what is happening like I got you know
you think you know you think that you
wouldn't get tired of hearing the name
of Jesus but and so at some point I was
like what is happening so I go out and I
go to see my neighbor to like see like
what is this and I walk in and it's just
him with one boy and he's just like he's
going and going and going I thought you
know it's like we go to church on Sunday
morning you know and sometimes I don't
go because it's too long Tourette's much
traffic it's down in the city and like I
don't make it all the time and and I
think it's like wow you know in Africa
especially people are so spiritual it's
like it just takes up their whole life
so much that me as a westerner like I
get tired of it like can you stop
praying please right now like you're
actually criticizing someone for being
totally immersed anyways so that's my
little Africa that's kind of totally off
the track there little Africa and
anybody anybody who's who's done that
kind of work you just you just get so
many stories I'll often tell people if
you're looking for something to do right
out of college go overseas and live in a
poor community for you know for five or
ten years or something you will learn
more in that process than you can
possibly imagine and and I think I think
actually that I don't think it's
accidental that these third culture
experiences you know in some ways
connect with what Peterson is doing and
I think especially with respect to your
symbolism because
that it forces you to think in other
ways and have have respect for other
cultures and not simply be reactive
dismissive which is or either dismissive
or seduced like people yeah either
either dismiss other cultures or think
that you know other cultures are just
the most amazing thing that ever
happened one of the most amazing in
terms of symbolism one of one of the
most amazing experiences that I had was
in Congo I was I was working with
artisans and we were designing products
that were being that were being sold
locally but also sold internationally so
kind of helping them jive with what the
international market wants and then
design products based on that and one of
the experiences I had was I met a son of
the of a tribal king of the kuba king
and the kuba they have these amazing
patterns they have these geometric
patterns that they use on cloth and in
carving and everything and it's a really
elaborate symbol system and when I saw
and I thought this is more than just
geometric pattern it's like there is
definitely something meaning happening
in these patterns and so I interviewed
him for hours and hours and I was
recorded the interview and he was
explaining the Simba the the geometric
patterns and thus they're each geometric
pattern had a story that was related to
it and then that pattern was used only
in certain instances let's say on
certain for certain things and so it all
of a sudden its I had this amazing
vision into like a proto it's a really a
symbolic language like a full-on fully
developed symbolic language of geometric
relationships and the end and it was
really related to the symbol it was
almost like the symbols were kind of
like abstract images and depending on
what was happening in this symbol it
actually meant something and and that
was one of the things that it was weird
because discovering traditional African
art it really bolstered my desire to
make traditional Christian art because I
was seeing this amazing language and
obviously I'm not going to come back
here and make African art there we have
so the absurd it's like coming back to
Canada and then saying no I'm gonna
plunge into into the history of
Christian art and see if I can find
those same those same patterns there and
I mean obviously I had already kind of
seen that they were there so it was just
natural that I would go from let's say
living in Africa and coming here and
doing what I'm doing now it seemed very
weird but in the end it's actually quite
natural that that happened that way it
makes sense it makes sense and for me to
be the the way that culture so for
example the Haitians I'm working with
many of whom had been Christians already
but through successive waves of often
American influence but of course the
Roman Catholics had gotten there first
so then you have all of this all of
these ideas all mixed together along
with ideas you know if they're Haitian
so there who do comes from western
Africa and and you just have all these
layers of this and this then gets
manifest so one of the things that often
happened we'd have these baptisms well
you get missionary stories here we go
we'd have these baptisms and I should
you know you got these pictures are all
these people dressed in white you're
coming down the river you think okay
this is kind of an American Baptist
thing and then they go into the water
and because I'm way out I'm way out
there in terms of where we're at we're a
long ways from the capital and you take
the person for baptism and you put him
in the water but now for Haitians
there's spirits in the water and and
this kind of connects in with the
ancient Christian connection between
baptism and exorcisms and cleansing the
spirits of the body so the pastor puts
the whoops puts the person there
baptizing into the water and then
there's battle and that's then the
person starts to thrash and and then the
pastor grabs them and puts them in again
and they're still thrashing the pastor
just keeps putting them in until finally
they surrender and and so what happens
sometimes as some missionaries or even
some pastors from the Capitol it come
and they look at this made oh you know
this is this is
horrible this is wrong and and III was
always of the sense of no this is this
is theology manifesting itself as
Peterson talks about in drama
this is theology manifesting itself in
drama it's not a pretend drama for them
that you know this is what's happening
in Baptism is that you know old Adam is
being drowned that's one way to say it
or you know that the spirits that have
been inhabiting this person are being
drowned and cast out and so I always
looked at this practice which I think
developed completely naturally in this
context with all the successive layers
of culture and said well this is this is
the gospel working itself through all of
this culture and and also on the
metaphysical level too because I don't
think I think it's hard to live in a
context like that and walk away a
materialist see too much stuff yeah and
it's interesting because that is really
let's say the ancient way where we still
in our in our church when there's a
baptism before the baptism there's an
exit there's an exorcism of the person
and then not only Nexus ism of the
person but there's also like a chasing
of the of the dragons from the water
like in the in the in the prayer it's
like one of my favorite services and
even during a theophany - like during
the the Feast of the baptism of Christ
we took we talked about like these
dragons that are hiding in the deep
waters and so like we cast out these
dragons from the deep waters and so yeah
for me that's why I mean coming back to
Jordan when he kind of talked about you
know that these the idea of chaos and
the dragon at the at the bottom of the
let's say of the deep and all that it
just made total sense but it's still
really part of of our of our worldview
and it's there in the Bible it's there
to it the whole idea of of the splitting
of the waters and then the idea of Jonah
going down into the waters all these
images are going down into water all
have to do with this is going down into
death is going down into chaos all the
way up to to st. Peter who goes down in
the water and Christ pulls around it's
like there's this thread of water which
I'll probably make a video about it
I did do I talk about the often in one
of my videos kind of explaining that
that thread that goes in to to that but
definitely I think that the West like or
lint the modern world like I would say
the West but it really it's the modern
world the modern world has has lost the
capacity to see those natural
connections that are are so intuitive to
us right they're just so natural well we
actually have to fight to to stop them
from from coming up but once you've once
you've kind of fought them then they
they're not there they still appear it's
like the reason why people play video
games is because they can inhabit that
world like that the world of video games
is is basically made it's basically a
traditional world with the whole the
whole structure of video games is is
usually like some monsters kind of like
dark under under something and then the
and there in the world its world is flat
and and there there's a map and and the
edge of it is kind of chaotic and so
it's always that world is so deep in us
that if you make our world a ball that
floats up and around the Sun we're going
to make a world for people to flee from
that abstract world and go go live in it
right that's right that's right
and and so part of where so when I was
in seminary for example the the work of
Robert alter who's a Jewish scholar and
Berkeley was was was really kind of
hitting it stride and and what altar did
was kind of change the conversation
which had been focused on this
grammatical historical scientistic
tradition of biblical interpretation and
said now wait a minute there's this
there's intentional structure within
this literature yeah and and that then
became kind of a half step to say so
that for me I stopped I a lot of the
commentaries that have been written were
just completely useless as a pastor
because nobody cares how many different
documents there were you know behind the
Old Testament nobody cares and these new
Bibles these new Bibles are our death
for church like the Bible is with like
the texts that are kind of like not
really in the tacks or that have a
different different because it's like
this is an addendum and there's all
these quotes I know this was part of
tax and this outside cold man does it
like why would you use a a Bible like
that in church like you use it to study
but in church you want something you can
read right you want an oral like
something you can participate it that's
a treat and unfortunately so so the
Christian Reformed Church was was kind
of a in the Netherlands a break away
from a modernistic Church and so part of
the part of the blessing of some of
these rather even biblic traditions you
know today even maintaining the King
James which is an interesting
translation I don't personally use it a
lot but you know at least within those
realms for example as a child what did I
learn I learned Bible stories yeah and
you get enough of these Bible stories
and you know modernists of all these are
well you don't want to tell children
these stories it's like no you don't
understand what a child is I remember
had our church
early on one of the mothers wanted to
outlaw sticks because the boys were
making swords and it's like they're boys
you know if you take away some no we
don't want to give them guns well guess
what you're gonna cut off their fingers
I mean this is how we are so leave the
kids alone and yeah they're gonna get
poked and stuff but for the most part
we'll all get through and and the Bible
is like that it's this enormous
playground and and so a lot of what I
discovered over the years just doing
basic pastoral work and because I have
to preach every every week from the
Bible
doing all this Bible study I began to
see these connections and say hey wait a
minute
something's going on here that we didn't
talk a lot about at seminary
why not already so before discuss before
seeing Jordan you had already started to
see or you already had some some insight
into the fact that the Bible story is
functioning in these in these these
patterns like that there's a pattern
that run through and go all the way to
to the end basically okay well it's
interesting cuz I grew up I grew up in a
Protestant church and like there was
gonna there was gonna be none of that
where I grew up I remember I have this
crazy story of a someone I love dearly
who who was told that the word snake in
that it says that the word the snake was
was crafty right in Genesis or that was
wise or something and learned that the
word meant that it was naked and and it
was like he was getting a hammer on his
head like he was getting his whole world
who being shatter and he said well does
that mean that we need to give a
spiritual meaning to the story in
Genesis I was like what 19 years old and
already I was like you mean you don't
you don't see like you don't see that
it's a story like even if you even if
you believe in it literally still it as
a spiritual meaning I hope or else like
what is it for like who cares about it
and I think you know also what what I
think a missing piece is if you I don't
know if you're familiar with a another
Protestant named Eugene Peterson he
another Peterson he's very big in in the
Protestant in the Protestant world he
was a PC us a pastor he's retired now
but you know one of the one of the real
issues the church has to figure out in
this secular frame is what is the word
spiritual mean yeah because it has so
many current meanings that we're not
paying any attention to and this is part
of the this is part of so so I start
listening to Peterson and I'm thinking
all right well what do you mean by that
and archetypes all right well what do
you mean by that and so actually a lot
of what I've had to do in the last few
months is to try to try to kind of nail
things down and figure out Peterson's
vocabulary because he's using terms that
in different context mean different
things and so then it's really important
because as he keeps telling us I I'm
very intentional about my words he keeps
saying that and he's right he is and so
some of these skills that I use in terms
of grammatical interpretation I kind of
apply to Peterson and I track down all
these little video tapes and say okay
he's using it here in this context and
he's using it there in that context
what does he mean by being and and now
in some recent videos he's he's talking
more about metaphysics which is very
interesting be and and so ok well and
and I think it's it's it's a it's very
interesting to me why certain things
come up and why everybody already almost
always focuses right down in on the
resurrection mmm-hmm because that's
that's where the resurrection is one of
these points where all of the streams
come together just like the crucifixion
yeah and and so yeah everyone's drawn to
this point say well what do you think
about the resurrection and then you know
pearls is brown I don't like answering
these questions and you know because he
says I'm not smart enough to figure it
out and so maybe in three years I'll
know and so but I think one of the
things about the resurrection which is
important to say and I and I think that
I think that Christians overestimate
their capacity to understand what the
resurrection is definitely you know and
so I think that if you look into the
text and you read what's actually what
it actually says it's not at all obvious
what in terms of phenomena the
resurrection is I mean Christ hides in
his own resurrection you know he he he
appears and the the disciples don't
recognize him and then finally they
recognize him and he they recognize him
because he does a certain thing and and
so it's it's it's made in the text
itself it wants to get take away the the
simplicity of thinking that the
resurrection just made a dead corpse
sitting up and walking out you know
there's something else happening and the
idea of what it means for his body to be
glorified what all these things mean
like it's it's not at all simple and if
then if you add what st. Paul says about
the resurrection and he talks about
spiritual bodies and you talk like what
exactly do you even know what what would
what exactly is a spiritual body it's
like it seems like that's a total
contradiction in terms and so if he's
using an aporia to talk about something
something which is can't you that's like
either either spiritual or it's a body
if it's a spiritual body then he's he's
he's definitely creating a category that
transcends other categories or a
category that
is beyond our capacity to understand it
and so I think that one of the reasons
why people have one of the reasons why
people have been hounding me they've
been hounding me about the resurrection
to like what and I'm like okay well I
think the resurrection is an event I
definitely believe that and I believe
it's a it's an event that happened but
if you think that you can contain that
event in your cat in your little
definitions then you're you're you're as
much I would even say you're as much a
heretic as the person who denies it that
that that resurrected body is not at all
an obvious thing to understand and I
think that's exactly right so empty
right has written about his ante right
rights more than anyone can read I think
but he you know he's written about as
much on this as anyone and and the point
he keeps making again and again is that
all of these texts bear seem to bear
testimony not of a group of people
arranging their stories to fix to
somehow develop a theological point but
they bear witness to events that they
couldn't comprehend and so what the New
Testament spends its time doing and
actually I think one of my favorite
books in the New Testament is the book
of Revelation because I think
essentially a book of Revelation is an
attempt to update the Old Testament
prophetic books with the new revelation
of Jesus Christ and in many ways the
only terms the the best tools they had
at hand were symbolic tools in an
attempt to represent the events that
they're trying to come to terms with and
so then again I listened to so this is
where you know this is all stuff that I
knew and think about and work on and all
this and then I listened to Peterson and
I hear him talking about this this
psychological you know this
psychological process by which we come
to create symbols and how these symbols
get refined over time and and eventually
inscripturated and and you know and then
I began to say
this is this is really useful not as in
a sense explaining away the Bible or
Christian belief or traditional
Christianity but I think actually in
terms of saying here is we don't know
the process but here is a plausible way
we can understand why the Bible has the
shape it has and why it's enduring why
it's had this enduring power trans
culturally throughout time why you can't
shake this book and why you can't shake
these images and so when you get to the
book of Revelation other things that you
recognize is that at least in Protestant
hymnody so much of our hymn that he
comes from the book of Revelation
because it is just so rich but we're all
children before some some great thing
that we can't possibly understand well
that if you look at in the Orthodox in
the Orthodox Church we don't we never
quote the book of Revelation we never
there's no readings of the Book of
Revelations in the liturgy okay really
right but the entire structure of the
liturgy itself and the entire structure
of iconography is based on the Book of
Revelations and so the way the church is
built the Christ the image of Christ in
the dome of of an Orthodox Church that's
the Christ who's returning at the end of
time right and so the structure and then
below him there's a hierarchy of angels
and then below the hierarchy of angels
then there are the disciples of the
prophets and the disciples and then it
comes down down down and then we are
kind of part of that whole and so the
whole church is an image of the Last
Judgement in a way or the eschatological
manifestation of the total Church and so
although although the although we don't
use the text in in the liturgy in terms
of courting it like the entire the
entire liturgy is based on on on on
it's based on on revelations and so yeah
so when you say that the hint that it
comes into the hymns in parts and hymns
it just makes sense because that's what
in terms in terms I think in terms of
the more orthodox perception of
revelations is that it's it's a cosmic
it's like the ultimate cosmic puzzle a
guilt met cosmic image of the totality
of all things and then the church is in
a way like the kind of the temporary
manifestation or not the temporary but
let's say like the thematic one of the
manifestations of the heavenly Jerusalem
which comes down and so the church is is
the heavenly Jerusalem physically the
way it's made with Christ coming down
and say and then the altar with the lamb
on the altar you know and all that comes
from the Book of Revelations when people
a lot of when people talk about you know
when I where I was growing up in the in
the Evangel church I we didn't have an
altar and they would say no we don't
have an altar because we're not in the
Old Testament anymore and you don't want
altars but in the altar and the church
doesn't come prevail Testament it comes
from revelations that's where the altar
comes from the lamb on the altar and and
and the idea that it flows out like his
blood or the or the river that flow out
into the into the world then that is
then joining that with communion and
bringing communion out to the people
it's all these images that are kind of
fused to create what has become the
liturgical liturgical service so maybe
that's that's like maybe a big question
that I want that I want to ask you is
that as you start to see the stories and
the patterns and and the idea that there
are these structures let's say in in the
patterns and the stories that are the
way we're made and we could even say the
way we're made in God's image let's say
it's it that way how does that affect
the way that you would see then like a
church service because in terms of the
Orthodox tradition you would say that
the reason why we have liturgy is
because we we participate in that we
actually live in the patterns and then
we act it out and it's not it's not so
much a theatre the way Jordan presents
it that's one of the places where I
disagree with Jordan like he tends to
say we act it out before we understand
it I don't think that I don't think
that's the right way to see it I think
that we we inhabit it so that the
patterns can become we acted out as a
group right in terms of a community so
that the patterns become the unifying
the unifying structure which holds the
group together and so you know the
procession the bowing all these things
they create a they create a way that we
can physically and spiritually
participate in that giant pattern which
is basically the Bible or ultimately
like the Book of Revelations I'd say
like the final manifestation of all
those those patterns into one kind of
crazy you know story so I'd like to know
like kind of how you because I know that
the Protestant I mean the Protestant
ethos or the Protestant tradition tends
to emphasize more the sermon and let's
say some hymns in the sermon so maybe
you could talk about that a little bit
well that's a big conversation when I
guess coming in here
no I didn't and and but it's a really
important conversation so I'm my little
church was like the first Christian
Reformed Church that was planted in
Sacramento because Hollanders moved in
here and then it was in an
african-american community because the
crazy missionary said you know all these
all these second and third generation
Islanders want to make money and have
nice houses but here the black folks are
you know they're interested in the
gospel and so that's kind of how my
church got going and and I grew up in a
church that was similar in some ways
because it was here my father was
planting a church amongst
african-americans so so I had
liturgically I have this this Dutch
Calvinist liturgy and then an
african-american twist on it and then I
went overseas and so liturgical II I'm a
complete catastrophe but I just them I
mean I'm one of these beasts that comes
out of the sea and the Book of Daniel
I've got different heads and arms and
body parts and I'm a mess but so one of
the things that we've been doing in
Sacramento are planting new churches and
one of the things that's been
interesting is that a lot of the younger
church planters are far more far better
attuned to liturgy and and I won't I got
to be careful here because some of my
friends will watch this video and I
don't want to rat them out but there's
some there's some serious
there's some serious Orthodox and Roman
Catholic and be going on in the heart of
a lot of Protestant church planters for
the reasons you just described because
they have seen how liturgy can
especially I think culturally right now
can can help younger people get the
gospel at a different level via liturgy
than they can through let's say a sermon
and so in the Midwest where the culture
is a little different when they do a
church plant they're still kind of in
this seeker mode with guitars and you
know big music and big sounds and a ball
pool and all that kind of stuff out here
on the west coast a lot of church plants
you know when they plant that the thing
they're doing is they're having weekly
Eucharist they're calling it Eucharist
and not Lord's Supper they're they're
paying a lot of attention to liturgy
they are including much more symbolism
now again and my iconoclastic tradition
I got to be careful with some of these
things they can't go full-blown icons
but this is happening in church plants
because church planters of any more than
any other type of pastor usually are
much more sensitive to what's happening
in the culture and and so they're saying
you know the sermon alone can't carry
the freight we need to embody this in
liturgy and this is bringing young
church planters to study liturgy and and
and and and and and bring in a lot of
elements that were cast out and the
Protestant Reformation and and and let's
see that's not entirely fair either
because if you actually look at John
Calvin John Calvin had weekly Lord's
Supper
John Calvin loved
church fathers um a lot of this stuff
that gets associated with real
iconoclastic bear Protestantism is
really 3rd 4th 5th generation things
that happen further on down the line so
when you get into say Luther who's first
generation and Calvin who's second
generation a lot of that stuff from the
church fathers was still in there and I
think as modernity really got going
people decided that they wanted to keep
up with the cultural Joneses and that's
when you know liturgy kind of goes out
the window in some cases and that's when
you know that kind of what I call the
iron box of secularism really gets in
and so now we're gonna we're gonna
DeMuth ala gize the Bible and we're
gonna take on all this stuff and we're
gonna study it as scientists study you
know something over here so a lot of
this a lot of it there's if you dig down
deep into Protestantism the the
possibilities are not as grim as they
might appear in 1975 of angelical ISM
well I'd see it seems like I think that
what you're saying I'm getting a whiff
of that too in terms of I've noticed
that certain that there is a I think
that with the breakdown of modernity I
think there is something positive that
post modernity brought in terms of its
capacity to show the limit of just
rationality or the limit of only you
know living up in the mind and the
necessity for the embodied experience
let's say which which goes with it which
can go towards the more pendant clinic
hostile experiential stuff but that has
it's as its has its own limits and its
own downside let's say but I think I
mean at least for me it has been the
going towards the more let's say into
integrative and symbolic understanding
and these patterns as well because the
patterns the patterns we intuitively get
them right if you can explain them
properly you know and that's why I think
that's why I think a lot of people also
they like what would Jordan is saying
because he has
no matter where he gets it from like
even if it's from young you know even if
I don't like young or whatever there's
some of the patterns that Jordan gets so
intuitively that he's really integrated
I'm very profoundly so when he gives an
example if people just it just you can
people just click like they're like yeah
okay yeah that makes absolute sense and
I think that that's something that if we
as Christians can go back into the Bible
and go back into those stories and and
find those those those those gold
nuggets then then then we can do the
same when we talk about patterns to
people and we say you know that's why
that's one of the reason why I'm doing
these movies interpretations is to say
these are the patterns of reality people
like they're not they're not just in the
Bible they're in reality so it'll appear
all over the place I can I can show you
like okay here here's a kind of less
profound but still it's still there like
and it's the same as when King David did
this and when you know and so I think
that that's an interesting way to to be
able to awaken people to to to to these
to like the structure of reality
basically and then final and hopefully
it will help them see that there's
something you know that there is a
transcendent aspect which which goes
beyond all of it and which kind of out
of which everything flows couldn't like
it it's it's interesting to see what's
happening now who knows it's hard to
know exactly how all of this is going to
how all of this is going to go but for
sure it's an exciting time to to kind of
be alive and to be able to talk to
people yeah it sure is it sure is oh and
I you know and part of what this project
for me has been getting my mind around
technology because I have also always
been interested in technology and so
part of me figuring out okay what does
what does YouTube mean and because what
we're seeing now so what I've done at
some of my videos is you know if you
look at John Walton who's a who's a
scholar from Wheaton Wheaton College old
testament basically ancient Near East
cultures their impact on the Old
Testament you know he reminds he reminds
people that first you know before before
the Bible was
scripture rated it was it was likely
oral and and so YouTube is in a sense
the new orality and and so I've been for
example I've watched obviously way a lot
of hours of Peterson videos and now I'm
reading his book and and Jordan Peterson
in text and I'm also singing the
audiobook which is Jordan Peterson's
voice but Jordan Peter Peterson reading
his book is different from Jordan
Peterson on YouTube mm-hmm okay how what
does that mean how does that work how
does that change things and so you know
I think you know especially when it
comes to liturgy well what are you doing
with liturgy so you're taking stuff from
the printed page and now you're in a
sense you know let's think about tang
you know you're you're taking it and
your life right congregation yeah well
it was there right in the beginning I
mean it was there from the beginning
that the the the Hebrew text was only
consonants and you can you can see it
really in that way where it's like a
dead thing it's only it's only stop
sounds right it's only it's only
guttural sound and stop sounds and then
you literally breathe into the text you
literally add the vowels which are the
the the breathing and the the the the
continuity so as so the text would take
life as you would read it out loud
because it's not actually even fully
there in the in the ribs right it's not
even fully there like that the meaning
is actually missing from it and the
meaning the meanings plural of also were
kept in the community and kept as an as
an oral disc tradition it had to be
because each word maybe had for several
words would have several possibilities
of interpretation so so yeah so there's
definitely a deep aural I mean even the
idea of reading scripture in private
it's it's not it's not a pretty recent
thing which comes with with modernity
like Scripture it was made to be read
out and that's why I like even in the
Orthodox Church until today we have
these sooo
for long services like during during
Lent during Holy Week we had these long
services that read like the 3d 12
Gospels of the the fashion and they go
on for like three hours and they just
read everything and we have these we
have during during the during Lent and
and Holy Week we have these these
services where there's like all the
readings from the Old Testament wherever
almost every single prefiguration of
Christ is like read out loud so you
stand there for like five hours like
listening at least American Protestant
ations boy we go for hours no forever
yeah Africans too like they they you
know like churches they're like they
live and breathe it you know they just
keep going forever yeah we get grimy
night I struggle through these long
services oh my goodness the Russians and
we sit down like the Russians they don't
sit down like they have we have chairs
in the on the sides of our church where
you could sit you for me too but the
Russian just stand for five hours you
know like the iron legs one of the
things that one of the things that
impresses me is these ancient practices
endured and they formed communities and
people and beliefs in ways that for all
of our technological flashiness you know
we're we we just I think I think we are
I think in many ways and CS Lewis makes
this point often I think we are as a set
in the Sun and the Lord of the Rings we
are we are lesser sons of greater men
yeah you know because these these
practices in these communities that we
so quickly dismiss you know built
civilization and you know and and and
developed faith that you know the or
that the Russian Orthodox Church you
know they endured they endured
mewn ISM and you know the and the the
Chinese Church you know grew and took
root during communism and and so there's
there's very much kind of a Darwinian
there's a very much a Darwinian reality
that it's I mean these these churches
have been purified and and yeah they're
their churches so they got all they got
all our messed up baggage with them too
but I think we we are so dismissive when
we should be respectful yeah yeah all
right I think we've gone for quite a
long time that's right exactly so maybe
we could we will attract we'll do this
again at some point
that'd be great that's all I will do I
will dev I will wish you all the best I
thought I'd follow your your YouTube
channel and i wish you all suggested
people go and check it out i wish you
the best as you continue to talk to
people and try to to mince out show the
good and and you know how jordan
connects to christianity how he
disassociates himself christianity
trying to find that balance that's
something that i that i try to find
myself in terms of my discussion with
people too I always tell people okay
Jordan is a heretic like that's it's
obvious that he's a heretic he makes he
does everything to tell you that he's a
heretic that he started he's told you
that he started his own church colleges
could say Joachim of flora like what
more does he have to tell you the
heretic okay no once you've gotten that
don't write 10 page like articles about
how he's a heretic he's told you that
he's a heretic now let's move on to
something else and have a real
discussion right it's like so hopefully
we can keep doing that yeah thank you
and thank you for having me and thanks
for this conversation this was I really
have appreciated your work and I you
know I've got a you mentioned I've got a
preach a sermon and on the Moses and and
the bronze serpent and I thought oh boy
I've you've got resources in that that I
don't have back here and so I really I
appreciate your work and I really pray
for God's blessing on your word
your family and and on your little
church I'm thank you thank you for that
story I'll I'll have a whole nother
image now of of you and your and your
blessed tribe and I do pray that that
God blesses you richly
I think thanks a lot thanks for the
preciate it so until next time
all right all right thanks all right
take care
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your comments in the
comment section below please go ahead
and share this on social media to all
your friends and also please consider
supporting us financially on patreon
you'll find a link to the patreon page
in the description below